jusqu'à la chaleur talent et enfin plus
haut c'est si tu te sens bien comme ça
aurais-tu je me sens bien comme ça tu te
souviens quand on s'est rencontrés se
rappelle en était c'était beau
je suis michael c'est moins qu'au fils
je suis l'enfant qui a mis au monde
je suis heureux je suis mort est gratuit
et vivante
je me suis de leur mort c'était prévu et
se paie revenir je te demande d'être
présent dans la vallée de la mort le 12
novembre 2014 tous les deux oui tu as
bien lu toi et papa
tu pourras croire à une mauvaise blague
mais je te jure que cela crée des liens
planning des endroits où vous devez
aller le jour précis il aurait eu quatre
heures 4
bien plus
arrête toi arrête toi notre fils de
demande de faire cette chose pour lui
que là pour lui
tu vas faire ce qu'ils demandent
et
elle vient de cette chemise je trouve ça
fait beaucoup
à peu
je désirais une fois tu te souviens tu
vas confondre je crois pas non